Okay, so...
Here are my Nicolas Cage bear jokes.
Waka waka, whore!
Papa bear says this bitch is TOO CONSCIOUS!
The Berenstain Family says hi!
Allow me to introduce myself: I'm Winnie the SHUT-THE-F*CK-UP!
The bare necessities would like you to get more acquainted with the ground!
*singing*  Gummi Bears, bouncing here and there and in your FACE!
Sister Rose, meet Brother Bear!
I hear you've been harnessing pic-a-nic baskets!
Padddington told me we should meet face to fist!
Can't get enough of that Golden Crisp, it's got the crunch with punch!
And the number one Nicolas Cage bear joke is...
Only you can prevent not getting your ass kicked by Nicolas F**KING Cage!
Play me off, Paul!
*Paul Shaffer plays him off*